the fury of the hurricane is expected within
the hour the weather bureau reports winds near
the center of the storm in excess of 100
miles an hour if you have not heeded the
weather Bureau's official warning and
evacuated to safety you should do so
at once however when the storm hits do not
attempt to go outside stay in your home or
shop I don't see the jacksons anywhere Oh Fred
said he was gonna ride this one out at home
is it getting worse friend maybe but we're
safe enough shouldn't we have gone with I'm
sorry Fred I won't say it again just
don't worry I wish you'd boarded up
that window thus the long anxious wait and
as in almost every community in the path
of the storm some have heeded the
official warnings others have not
once again a hurricane sweeps out of the tropics
and strikes at the mainland of the United States
the probability that this will happen every year
perhaps even several times a year is something
we must accept more than 150 hurricanes have
hit the United States in the past 60 years yet
even with this alarming frequency we are prone
to minimize or forget the danger and tragedy
of hurricanes survival depends upon many things
adequate advance warning that disaster is going
to strike a community plan to protect its people
and the willingness of everyone to follow official
instructions a hurricane your hurricane perhaps
might be detected one morning by meteorologists
aboard a weather airplane a unit of the hurricane
hunters whose mission is to locate and observe
tropical storms that might grow into hurricanes
scores of tropical disturbances occurred during
the hurricane season which usually reaches its
peak in August and September only a very few
of these storms will develop into hurricanes
it's the job of the weather bureau to detect
those that do develop to track them to predict
their course to issue forecasts and warnings
weather forecasting requires accurate and timely
information new instruments are constantly being
put into use radar weather observing devices
electronic computers and improved equipment
for use on aircraft all make it possible for
the weatherman to do a better job of predicting
and forecasting Tyros weather satellites which
orbit in outer space and transmit pictures of
clouds to ground stations are expected to be the
forerunners of a new era in weather forecasting
Act receive satellites are revealing weather
phenomena formerly unknown to man they will
amplify what is already known about hurricanes
hurricanes originate over water as tropical wind
storms when the winds reach a speed of more than
73 miles an hour the storm is officially called a
hurricane and given a name girls names are used
because they have proved to be the shortest and
least confusing way of designating the storms
the names are selected by the weather bureau the
hurricane is accompanied by extremely heavy
rainfall the winds revolve counterclockwise
about a central calm area an area known as the
eye the diameter of the eye may vary from 3 to
60 miles thus when a storm passes over a period
of relative calm will last from a few minutes to
perhaps an hour depending upon the diameter of the
eye and the forward speed of the storm hurricanes
move forward at 12 to 15 miles an hour in the
tropics but may travel as fast as 60 miles an
hour in northerly latitudes the area affected by a
hurricane may be as small as 30 miles in diameter
while in large storms the diameter may be as much
as 1,000 miles hurricanes are extremely erratic
and most difficult to forecast they can veer off
in all directions even backtrack on their course
sometimes tornadoes are a byproduct occurring on
the perimeters of her games however tornadoes are
usually born of thunderstorms far inland from
hurricanes and remote from them the boiling
funnel shape makes them easily recognized the is
vicious deadly storms are similar to hurricanes
in that they are cyclonic a violent vortex in the
atmosphere unlike hurricanes they cut narrow paths
when they strike the earth sometimes only a few
yards wide the length of their paths is usually
less than 16 miles their winds rotate at speeds
up to 500 miles an hour the most violent force
in all nature they are far more frequent than
hurricanes more than 800 have occurred in the
United States in a single year their destructive
effects are terrifying to forecast the development
of dangerous weather conditions the weather
bureau established a severe local storm warning
center the specialized staff forecast severe local
storm conditions during the summer and fall when
most tropical disturbances occur forecast offices
maintain a systematic watch for the development
of hurricanes when it is definitely determined
that a tropical storm is formed even though it is
hundreds of miles from the mainland observation of
the storm becomes continuous at frequent intervals
advisories are issued which report all that is
known about the storm where it is its intensity
speed and direction the reports are constantly
updated by new information through the cooperation
of the Air Force the Navy the Coast Guard and the
Federal Aviation agency the weather bureau is able
to keep the storm under constant observation
reconnaissance planes make daily flights into
the eye of the storm for periods up to 6 hours
at a time with the constant stream of data they
transmit the weather bureau can now begin to
predict the path of the storm as the storm moves
toward the mainland hurricane watch notices are
issued we have just received a bulletin from the
weather bureau which says a hurricane watch is now
in effect in this area hurricane conditions may
be felt here in 30 to 42 hours the weather bureau
says this means the public should be ready to take
precautionary action if it becomes necessary
to issue warnings as the hurricane approaches
reconnaissance airplanes gather information by
flying into the storm night and day tracking by
weather bureau and other radars especially along
the gulf and atlantic coasts is now constant
each radar can pick up the storm when it comes
within 200 miles to supplement all these reports
the weather bureau relies on a vast number of
observers on the coasts civil defense workers
public safety personnel and members of the Armed
Services qualified people who feed information
to local weather bureau stations the thousands of
amateur radio operators are particularly valuable
not only as sources of information but also in
providing a link with the world when all other
communications are out observations from ships at
sea are received at frequent intervals experienced
hurricane forecasters make their decisions from
the huge volume of weather information when they
determine that a particular section of the
mainland will feel the full effects of the
hurricane hurricane warning his issue hurricane
warnings according to an official u.s. weather
bureau bulletin are now in effect in this area
all persons living in coastal areas which may
be flooded by tides of 5 to 7 feet above normal
should move to high ground we are meeting here
today and northern make some plans months before
the weather bureau conducted local preparedness
meetings to alert responsible officials and
civic leaders to the dangers of such storms
the participants were selected well in advance
of the hurricane season so that they would be
prepared to activate government Coast Guard civil
defense police amateur radio operators and Red
Cross facilities and personnel these leaders make
it their responsibility to see that warnings are
widespread that all citizens are forewarned
that they understand evacuation plans how to
protect their property and their lives here is the
latest word from the weather bureau the hurricane
will strike our city in about 16 hours the bureau
suggests that you follow these safety precautions
and measures keep your radio or television on for
latest warnings and advisories battery-operated
cents no attention to rumors evacuate from
low-lying beaches which may be swept by high
tides or storm waves be alert for high water in
areas where streams or rivers may flood after
heavy rains board up windows tie down or remove
everything that might be blown away or torn boots
be sure to have plenty of gasoline in your car
get in extra food and drinking water don't under
any circumstances attempt to secure a boat during
the storm the greatest loss of life in a hurricane
is from drum if you are notified by officials to
evacuate your property do so you will be directed
to places of safety once again a community braces
itself prepares to withstand the tremendous
destructive force of a hurricane it's a howling
monster that destroys with savage ferocity get the
chances your chances for survival are excellent
if warnings are heated if precautions are taken
I keep worrying about the jacksons I wish they
were here well you know how Fred Jackson is
sort of stubborn Fred I do wish we'd gone
with with the others I've just go on what
I know about storms in these parts now don't
worry we'll get along fine but will they The
Jacksons have taken a frightful risk not like
their friends and neighbors here these people
are taking no chances they're not gambling
their very lives with the winds that killed